television video sharing streaming video
on demand where and how we watch our
favorite films and shows has changed
dramatically in recent years in order to
face the challenges of a rapidly
changing landscape any peas are
preparing to update the rules the
service via bus Internet aleem does
videos on our user le inheritor after
approve passes in pharmacy anishka
regard on des up to the doctor's these
are no longer s Linea the new proposals
include measures to help protect
children from violent or sexual online
content when users flag up harmful or
inappropriate material video platforms
and websites would in the future be
responsible for removing the offending
content for example the possibility for
adults to implement filtering software
on the on the devices of their children
also to have age verification systems
for content that might be harmful for
children that also be stricter rules on
advertising a maximum of twenty percent
broadcasting time should be set aside
for advertisements and more online
content will have to be European MEP say
this will support and encourage European
producers directors and artists
[Music]